[Music]
kindle and christian or they were all
smiles at the event last night but at
home yeah that's another story chris is
fuming about her ex's new tell-all I've
never been so angry why does everything
have to be that chris is such a [ __ ]
on Sundays keeping up Chris lashes out
over Caitlyn Jenner's new memoir the
secrets of my life which dishes on their
nearly 24 year marriage and published
excerpts Kaitlyn claims the sex was
quote not entirely comfortable and Chris
knew about the gender identity struggle
all through the book Chris knew Chris
knew before I even made love to her I'm
like what everything she says is all
made up so is this the Kardashian
matriarch sway of saving face before her
ex declares war in the media the
extended clip emerged just 48 hours
before her ex's 2020 sit down tomorrow
with Diane Sawyer promoting the book do
you ever have doubt that you did the
right thing it will mark two years since
Sawyer's first Jenner special watched by
more than 20 million where Kaitlyn also
made claims about Chris's treatment of
the transition the Diane Sawyer special
led people to have some misconceptions
specifically about you what you knew
when you knew back then she also seemed
to try to combat negative attention from
Kaitlyn just three weeks after Jenner's
interview aired Chris helped launch a
special called about roots which made
sure to showcase their past together as
a happy romantic couple the reason we
did it was just to show that
other people going through the same
thing what a family might go through
your relationship with Bruce now it's
great if they were civil back then now
and maybe played up for ratings not so
much not talking about it
[Music]
you